okay let's see no it's not a mirror
exercise mom has been on my youtube
channel so many times and she's out
you're visiting for Thanksgiving so I
thought I would exploit her one more
time if not two or three more times
before she leaves and make a video with
her I went on Twitter to ask you guys
for ideas for videos that we could shoot
together and someone said even though
it's a classic or an old kind of
challenge the whisper challenge might be
fun to do and I love the whisper
challenge and you don't know what it is
I do not know anything does it have to
do with speaking softly yes in this
challenge basically one of the two
people involved puts on some noise
cancelling headphones these are noise
canceling both we can just crank them
really loud then the other person tries
to say a phrase to the person wearing
the headphones but now you try and guess
what the person's saying okay I thought
because my mom is such a lovely positive
sweet person that instead of just
randomly picking phrases I found really
short inspirational quotes off of
Pinterest perfect that we can choose to
say sounds great and there's no real
winners or losers in this challenge we
just play until we're tired no everyone
wins that's not how the internet works
would you like to guess first or read
quotes first yes first you want to guess
first yes okay yes
so when I guess what do you want to
listen to I have got some relaxing
classical music right no we're gonna put
Taylor Swift's new album on for you I
like talents she's pretty sweet whoa
can you give me that is loud okay you
can also put your hands over first one
what perfectly imperfect
one more time
perfectly imperfect life is perfect
perfectly imperfect
you're so perfect perfect perfect
perfect perfect
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's not an iPad oh my gosh there's so
many good ones there's so many good ones
this fern should take this up real
Queens 30 Williams I'm finished
real Queens we hurting from Family
Matters is kind of lips real Queens fix
each other's crowns real Queens like
garbage
fix each other's crowns crowned Browns
hats crowns real queen fix each other's
crowns
oh my god ready create your own sunshine
again create your own sunshine grapes
grow in the bottle your own sunshine
'thanks make good one race now create
your grace it's my daughter that should
be one okay create your own sunshine
great roles on the show create your own
sunshine Rachel's not the money
this one is create your own sunshine oh
that's better
don't just exist with somebody in let's
do this the Navy don't just exist live
okay well thanks crazier babies yes
don't just live you have a really nice
smile to say something aspire to inspire
before we notice expired as fabulous
aspire to to uses extra make hands
inspires expires is the best inspired to
inspire my experience I tells you about
science aspire to catch fire before we
x-pyr hunchbacks afore munch fattest
aspire to is Taylor's people where we
enjoy higher this is a long one this is
a long one
enjoying the little things enjoy the
little things Julie like Santa things
enjoy the little thanks Jewish loves
other things enjoy the little things
enjoy the little
Thanks sure I love joy sure I love the
Lion King and Jeff that's good clothes
enjoy the little things should we why
don't we just come up with our own
sentences for each other like short
little things okay that makes sense for
us okay okay I'm your favorite child I'm
your favorite child you're so happy I'm
open I'm your favorite child your
favorite show I'm your favorite child
is that your favorite shop no I'm your
favorite child you're my favorite
daughter yeah you're my favorite child
she eats too good and be good you're a
big girl do good and be good you look
like me a little do good and be good you
like Nick Nick do good and be good you
love me
dude I do do good and you in the hood
you've been raised great do good you
could be good beer even beer do good
either be good you can be great then you
can have a beer oh good you can't be
good I was really fun though it's fun I
think our ABS have been totally worked
out thank you mom for participating
you're so welcome
I think I'm gonna shoot another video as
my mom before she leaves so leave a
comment down below letting me know what
other video we should shoot thank you
guys for watching subscribing to this
YouTube channel if you haven't already
other than that I don't know that was
great huh oh my god